euh mardi le Sénat a voté la suppression
de l'aide médicale d'État ame destiné au
sans papier à l'occasion de l'examen du
projet de loi immigration très
concrètement il s'agit d'une réforme en
fait visant à ne plus payer tous les
soins des personnes en situation
irrégulière et un second amendement qui
est passéerçu le Sénat a également voté
la fin des allocations familiales et des
aPL pour les étrangers en France depuis
moins de 5 ans ces deux gros de grosses
mesur qui sont passé un petit peu
inaperçu mais c'est incroyable plus de
soins et plus d'aloc ce sont des
décision qui font évidemment énormément
parler récap et ce sera le débat du jour
avec Stéphane Ravier de reconquête et
jamille ramani chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital
franco-britannique c'est parti
regardez cette semaine le Sénat examine
le projet de loi immigration et parmi
les amendements votés mardi soir la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État
destiné aux personnes en situation
irrégulière qui leur permet une prise en
charge des soins médicaux et
hospitaliers pour 200 contre 136
l'article est adopté une mesure qui
suscite la colère notamment de la gauche
on arrête de vouloir supprimer la me et
ce soirl les sénateurs ont aussi fait
voter un autre amendement controversé
qui vise à conditionner l'accord des
prestations sociales aux étrangers soit
vous nêtes pas sérieux soit on touche le
fond alors le Sénat veut arrêter de
soigner les sans papiers et supprimer
les allocations familiales pour les
étrangers êtes-vous
d'accord quel bonheur Jam de vous
recevoir alors vous nêtes plus chef du
service réanimation l'hôpital
franco-britannique exact vous êtes bon
je suis médecin anesthésiste voilà et un
excellent un excellent médecin on est
toujours content de l'avoir nous voir
souvent pendant la crise du covid
c'était un bonheur Stéphane Ravier merci
également vous êtes sur un bail de meuf
ça va non vous êtes au téléphone
j'envoie un petit une petite vidéo que
je viens de réaliser pour faire la promo
de votre émission qui en a bien
besoin t' pas avec ça ça va non non
occupe-toi plutôt de des résultats du
bon ça va bien ça va bien ça va bien
merci vous avez fait un petit un petit
post pendant le pendant le truc oui fait
un petit post c'est c'est pour le
Instagram c'est pour essayer de faire
juns ouais on dit plus Jun d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui non non non on dit plus mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave mais
c'est plutôt sympa allez on va passer au
débat du jour supprimer donc vous l'avez
vu le Sénat veut arrêter de soigner les
S papiers supprimer les locations
familial pour les étrangers êtes-vous
d'accord oui non oui non oui on va
d'abord faire le tour des des
chroniqueurs Jacques cardos vous êtes
vous dites oui je dis oui parce que
malheureusement les le le poids de ces
aides a considérablement augmenté depuis
70 ans je crois on est passé de 70000
personnes à 400000 qui est en bénéficie
je parle de des aides pour les étrangers
je parle de laame là en l'occurrence et
qu'elle est remplacée quand même par une
aide
d'urgence qui pourra permettre de
subvenir au besoins de d'un certain
nombre d'étrangers qui sont en voie de
régularisation puisque c'est de ça dont
il s'agit et oui malheureusement je
pense que tout simplement le le pays n'a
plus forcément les les les les
ressources pour faire face à toutes ces
aides donc tout ça a besoin d'être
réformé et moi je suis bien évidemment
c'est plus facile d'avoir le cœur sur la
main et c'est plus facile de dire que
tout le monde doit être doit pouvoir
accéder aux soins mais la réalité c'est
que en 70 ans on est passé de 40 de
70000 à 450000 personnes et que ça
augmente je crois de 12 % tous les ans
d'après les chiffres que j'ai pu voir en
tous les cas qui sont les chiffres
officiels donc oui je suis plutôt
d'accord oui et l'autre réalité c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de Français qui n'ont
pas accès au soins des personnes âgées
notamment qui n'ont plus les moyens de
se payer leurs propres soins ça coûte 1
milliard d'euros je crois cette aide
cette ame le fond il coûte 200 millions
d'euros donc si on peut économiser au
moins 800 millions d'euros pour que ça
bénéficie au français plutôt qu'à des
personnes qui pardon mais ne sont pas
censé être sur le territoire français
c'est une bonne chose c'est terrible
mais il faut être pragmatique c'est une
raison purement économique alors
Géraldine toi tu es pas d'accord non en
fait je pense que c'est pas binaire
c'està direire que je pense que ceux qui
disent oui sont pas forcément des des
méchants et voilà et ceux qui disent non
sont pas forcément des humanistes
extraordinaire je comprends
effectivement que dans un contexte de
pénurie de médecin de pénurie de l dans
les hôpitaux de pénurie de médicen ce
soit inaudible pour les français qu'on
soigne des sans papiers qui ne cotisent
pas qui ne payent rien par rapport à des
Français qui sont parfois dans le besoin
qui ont même pas de quoi payer leurs
soins médicaux je sais pas leur frais de
dentiste et tout ça je peux le
comprendre mais je trouve que voilà
laame c'est 1illard000 li auourd'hui et
je pense que il faut en fait pas il faut
pas supprimer il faut réguler il faut
calmer il faut limiter mais je pense
qu'on peut pas laisser des gens sans
papier qui sont malades et leur dire non
fait vous dég pour les malades graves
donc ça c'est très bien je trve que
c'est très bien les grossesses les
maladies graves des grosses vaccinations
pour des gens qui voilà qui on ont des
gros des gros problèmes de santé je
pense que c'est quand même l'honneur de
la France malgré tout de soigner de
soigner ces gens-là voilà vous dit bah
c'est toujours la même chose avant de
subvenir au besoins d'autrui il faut
déjà être en capacité de subvenir à ses
propres besoins et c'est combien 1illard
millions c'est ça ben je pense que cet
argent 70 millions pr voilà je pense que
cet argent on peut le mettre on peut le
mettre dans l'hôpital on peut le mettre
dans les logements on peut le mettre on
peut le mettre et le donner aux
retraités qui ont des petites retraites
je pense que la France en a déjà besoin
faut déjà qu'elle se guérisse elle-même
vous voulez dire quoi c'estàdire que bah
pour l'instant l'argent de la France
reste en France et pour France il sont
en France ils sont sur le sol
pour l'instant l'argent de la France
doit rester au français donc les sans
papierers pour vous ils doivent pas être
soignés une chose après l'autre
aujourd'hui il y a des Français souance
aujourd'hui non mais mais en fait c'est
c'est simple aujourd'hui il y a des
Français qui sont souffrance le jour où
le pays sera bon et il n'y aura plus de
Français en souffrance dans avec avec
des étudiants qui mangent pas leur faim
avec des personnes âgées qui est aussi
compliqué avec avec des gens qui ont pas
accès au soins des Français qui ont
travaillé tout leur vie tout ça quand
tout ça sera réglé on pourra donner
l'excédent d'argent à des gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur pour l'instant
ce n'est pas le cas donc je pense il
faut faire des priorités sauf que
Delphine de façon pragmatique comment
mais concrètement concrètement si les
gens savent que en France N a
plus il fond
d'Ur pour les maladies ur voil d'accord
acou bien sûr la évidemment à ce momentl
ça a été créé pour justement pour éviter
gr ép et tout ça mais maintenant les
gens se font recoller les oreilles c'est
complètement y a des exagérations
malheureusement et puis on a on a plus
les moyens excusez-moi mais a combien
qui sont fait recoller les oreilles
c'est un peu caricatural mais on en est
quand même un peu là excuse- laisse la
finir non mais ok mais c'est caricaturel
mais on en est là c'est complètement
dévoyé la Muu OK et et surtout ça fait
un énorme appel d' on est on ne peut pas
renvoyer les qtf on est incapable de
surveiller nos frontières il faut bien
qu'on fasse quelque chose ou alors on se
dit tous c'est très bien l'humanitaire
alors fait de
l'humanitaire vous trouvez que c'est
humain de laisser les gens les étrangers
qui sont bourrés de craqu qui qui qui
divag dans la rue vous trouvez que c'est
humain des enfants qui qui dorment sous
détente non alors on ne les prend pas
chez nous donc de toute façon on est t
on est tous inhumains ici parce qu'on
prend personne chez soi Mo je pass en
voiture je vois des enfants s je prend
pas chez moi donc je suis inhumaine vous
faites pareil on est tous inhumains
maintenant il y un moment où il faut
agir on ne peut plus on ne peut plus
faire ça tout il faut sauver la France
avant de sauver les situation
irrégulière excuse-moi mais tu te rends
compte y a des gens qui arrivent à parce
qu'il faut prendre un dossier faut
remplir un dossier c'estàdire qu'on va à
l'administration juste tu es sûr tu vas
pas trop vite mais non mais
je découvert
des j'ai découvert des trucs qui me
sembl surréaliste c'estàdire que un sans
papier va à une administration il
s'inscrit il a droit pendant un an à la
sécurité sociale alors que comme on le
disait il y a des gens qui payent des
impôts toute leur vie qui n ont à peine
qui ont à peine droit moi je on marche
sur la tête donc il faut ou alors on
laisse aller le pays comme ça ou on
prend des des dispositions qui sont
inhumaines je suis d'accord mais il y a
la mu excusez-moi pour vraiment on va
pas laisser crever les gens dans la rue
la MU est suffisante s'il vous plaît
juste un petit peu d'oxygène pour MAM
Valérie voulez lui dire un truc là il
est question de la suppression carrément
oui puisil y a à la place pour Mo est-ce
que tu penses sincèrement qu' faisant
cette suppression parce que visiblement
ce qui te fait peur c'est le flux
migratoire est- tuens pe toi que les
gens qui sont qui sont en train de
traverser des océans pour venir ici au
péril de leur vie c'est parce que tout
d'un coup génial en France on va pouvoir
se recoller les
oreilles JeanMichel va te répondre
JeanMichel va répondre
évidment le plus important c'est surtout
supprimer les allocations familial avant
il fallait 6 mois sur le territoire
régulier depuis 6 mois pour pouvoir
toucher les aloques maintenant il FAA 5
ans donc ça ça va quand même freiner les
gens qui venaient uniquement pour les
allocations famili pour les oreilles
mais non je pare il faut les soigner
mais les so les soins qui sont
importants les vaccins tout ça
évidemment mais en revanche tu peux pas
à la fois te plainre d'une trop grosse
immigration de qui est tant irrégulier
en France et en même temps faire tout
pour qu'ils s'y sentent bien à un moment
faut leur dire ne venez pas c'est pas le
paradis qu'on vous pret plus le paradis
jeis vous laisser tous vous exprimer et
après Jamine va nous expliquer aussi
vous allez voir ce que ça peut créer ça
on va en parler avec Jam vous allez voir
ce que va nous diream